نحن هنا نتواجد في مطار بن غريون الدولي
حيث يتواجد عشرات المتظاهرين الغاضبين
الذين يحاولون منع الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو من السفر الى
ايطاليا بسبب ما يعرف بتغيير نظام القضائي
وقاموا بعرقله حركه السير داخل شوارع
المطار بعد مراوغه قوات الامن التي سمحت
لهم بالدخول ظنا انهم من المسافرين لم
تعرقل هذه المظاهرات فقط رحله 60 الف
اسرائيلي سيسافرون من مطار بن غوريون
اليوم انما عرقلت زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
مرتين الى اسرائيل حيث قرر اجراء اللقاءات
مع صانعي القرار قرب المطار دون الدخول
الى البلاد ومن المتوقع ان تستمر هذه
المظاهرات طالما ان الحكومه مستمره في
الانقلاب على القضاء لا نقول غاصي في
المطار بن غريون العربيه